joël 17 ans apprenti à la manufacture
maija qui font nos apprentis 19 ans
rappelle jean-michel 14,1 fait école
qu'elle s'occupait vous le samedi après
midi avec des camarades dans les cafés
on trouve habitude grosses poubelles
dans les rues cafés tout ça quand les
balles le soir j'ai au cinéma la musique
julie le modèles réduits d'avions non le
chiot voiture
je m'appelle jean jacques j 18 ans et
parents sont bourgeois
j'aime beaucoup le cinéma je suis une
collection de porte-clés je serai comme
pour les maisons de jeunes sont
intéressés particulièrement pour ça
je m'appelle martin
tlj 16 ans
je regrette pas non plus une maison de
champagne particulièrement le potentiel
n'importe clair les poupées de
collection aussi le cadre justement pas
tout
moi ce que je cherche cherche à fair
noblesse mais votre âge
battant et va pas non un match donc ça
veut dire plus par me dire quels sont
vos occupations
un peu de tout quoi j'ai un peu de
guitare
quoi
vous travaillez pas ça suppose des
golden globes si vous ne l'avez pas non
plus mais quels sont vos loisirs
préférés en dehors de la musique
toutefois j'aime bien
j'aime bien emmener quoi le cinéma pour
question de cinéma télévision un peu
baby-foot les appareils électriques avec
à peine en belgique ce vote
qui perd là une moto non un vélomoteur
non plus non
22 ans étudiant en quatrième année de
droit alors j'aime beaucoup la chasse et
la pêche
or à poitiers fait une question de
loisirs je porte c'est un peu
il n'y a pas grand chose à part de trois
boîtes de nuit à rire quand violon
dingue je parle bien
atteint dire regardez parlement
mais dans le genre emails sont mal
organisées
money
22 ans j'aime beaucoup la danse la
natation
premier mandat
plon
très peu
sylvie 18 ans étudiante en droit
j'aime beaucoup la lecture natation adam
particulièrement
les corses ne regardez pas le temps
si la lecture
je suis les mains
je me collais slim
la nuit je suis étudiant dans un essai
technique et josip apache et pour quoi
faire
j'avais des copains au cinéma dimanche
aussi que quand je fais du sport dans
mon lycée il a alors mon violon dingue
c'est le sport n'est ce pas
pour fréquenter par les maisons de
jeunes aux quelques fois on sera uni
entre jeunes comme
on est dans une maison de jeunes non je
suis content
alors mon prénom c'est francisque je
suis étudiant en droit cha fac de droit
vous allez me demander à quoi je quitte
mes loisirs évidemment rabat poitiers
savez il ya pas tellement tellement de
loisirs alors le dimanche 20 contre
l'aso d'aller au cinéma soit d'aller au
bal bien encore le ca des balles vous
savez à la plupart du temps on est là se
balader dans les rues à se trimballer
les maisons de jeunes s'y installer oui
quelquefois quand on voit qu'un
programme nou lé pa rété ou au cinéma on
va maison de jeunes avec des copains
réunis mais sans plus ce qu'on vous
demande au nom
un débutant
alaba étudiants tunisiens ouais je fais
partie d'un groupe de jeunes ont fasciné
club photo club
ce qui occupe de loin de leurs fruits
dès le lendemain si la photo -
je suis ta photo
deux fois par semaine
on a dessiné clairement la tour le club
de théâtre